cuatro inmigrantes han sido evacuados
del barco Ocean viking de la ong sos
mediterráneo este jueves y han sido
trasladados a Francia países y al cual
se dirige este navío que navega
actualmente al este de La Isla francesa
de córcega pudimos comunicarnos con
personal de esta ong que confirmó que
decidieron dirigirse hacia Francia Ya
que en los últimos días las autoridades
italianas y maltesas según ellos han
ignorado decenas de mensajes del barco
solicitando acceso a un puerto para
desembarcar los 234 inmigrantes
rescatados en el mar Mediterráneo el
destino de estas personas ha abierto un
episodio de tensión diplomática entre
Francia e Italia después de
declaraciones del gobierno italiano que
agradeció en una nota de prensa a
Francia que aceptara el desembarco de
los Ocean Vikings en territorio francés
París sin embargo insiste en que es
quien debe hacerse cargo de este barco
Mientras tanto la situación a bordo
empeora hora tras hora personal de la
ong indica que algunos de los náufragos
llevan más de 18 días a bordo en
condiciones de higiene muy precarias
durmiendo en el piso algunos parecen
crisis de pánico de ansiedad y algunos
han iniciado una huelga de hambre